it really is it's it's a huge honor to
be here I love coming to this conference
I feel like I learned so much and you
know I'm probably the least capable our
programmer in this room and love coming
here and realizing everything I'm doing
wrong like I still set working directory
as even though Jared tells me every time
not to do that so so this is supposed to
be a stump speech about my research on
the stuff I'm doing using satellite
imagery and machine vision computer
vision but I want to convey something
that I've learned about it through my
research that are relevant for for you
guys so I retitled this talk so it was
using satellite imagery and machine
learning to estimate conflict in Syria
and poverty in Mexico I'm going to call
this wild speculation on the future of
data science from someone barely
qualified with two applications so and I
I think really the only the only thing
I'm way I'm wim qualified I think
there's two qualifications that are
important here is that I'm tall and I'm
Jewish so so this is of course is of
course from Jared's wedding all right so
so I do I do have some qualifications I
was hired by Chapman University after I
finished off my degree where I teach are
a machine learning to MBAs and
undergraduates and in fact I have two
undergraduate students here whereas
Nancy and Andre Nance where are they
yeah they're back there okay so 200
graduates Chapman flew them all all the
way out from from California this is the
first time they've been in New York City
Nancy has a job but Andre you were still
looking for a job is that correct so if
somebody is hiring if somebody is hiring
an entry-level data scientist I give my
word that Andre knows what he's doing so
so I teach so I teach MBAs and
undergraduates but in my research I
mostly work in development economics so
I tried to solve problems in development
economics and one of the problems that I
focus on our data gaps data gaps are
problems where we just
know a lot about the developing world
when one of the startling statistics is
that from the period of 2002 to 2011
there were 57 countries that just had
zero or one poverty estimate and if
you're somebody like me who cares about
poverty and reducing poverty the fact
that we're just not measuring this at
all should be very startling and you'll
see this throughout the developing world
we're just not measuring things that are
very important and so the reason why we
don't do a good job at this is because
it's just it's really expensive like you
have to physically send somebody to your
son's household you have to interview
them for an hour - and you have to
figure out basically how much income
they have their areas can be located
very far apart and so visiting each
household is very expensive so even like
a very large country like Pakistan
you'll survey maybe maybe 20,000
households once every three or five
years and in fact in Pakistan there
there are places like Jammu and Kashmir
or the Northwest Frontier Province where
you just never you just never send
surveyors there and another another like
startling fact is in Nigeria we actually
have no idea how many people there are
like estimates vary between 200 million
and 140 million because every time they
try to run a census the government just
deletes a bunch of people because they
don't want certain places to have more
populations like it's just very
startling and so so my work is about a
lot of it is filling in these data gaps
you know one of the more popular data
gaps ways to fill this is you know look
at satellite imagery so maybe some of
you are familiar with this imagery this
is what you know if you look at a
satellite image night you can kind of
tell well which one's North Korea and
which one's South Korea it's pretty
obvious US North Korea isn't one without
any lights so in case you're wondering
and and that works really well for gross
just kind of grow statistics but we're
looking to do something a little bit
more with with with our numbers so so
and in particular I'm interested in
these like not just like these
old-fashioned satellites or what I'm
interested in these really like frontier
micro satellites so these are there's a
there's a startup called planet that
releases these like
small satellites that are size of shoe
boxes and they currently have 190 in
orbit they have more satellites in orbit
than any other country besides the
United States and China and so they have
daily revisit rate of all of the Earth's
land mass and they can start you can
start doing some really crazy things
with this data so yeah and we're just
launching like a crazy number of imagery
satellites so if any of you are
searching for a dissertation topic it's
just probably something that like what I
did I was just like I have no idea what
to work on so I'm gonna start messing
with satellites because there's probably
something here so previous work that
I've done as I've tried to you generate
intermediate features from satellite
imagery so I use computer vision to
extract out the number of cars a number
of buildings so this is a raw satellite
image of Sri Lanka Iran kind of like an
off-the-shelf computer vision algorithm
against there I could figure out the
number of buildings I can figure out the
number of cars and I threw that used R
in order to just pump that through and
build a prediction model of the amount
of poverty in an area so to push that a
little further I wanted to see like
could I do this directly from daytime
satellite imagery using the fancy new
stuff a convolutional neural networks
directly and you can kind of tell like
like there's a lot so if we look on the
left we see that this is a very well-off
area in Mexico City so this area has
like large streets it has a lot of green
areas on the right this is a poor area
buildings are more regular they're a
little more closer together the streets
are kind of crappier and then the
poverty rates are are accordingly
so as we in the previous work I tried to
tell the computer what are the poor
areas what are the rich areas so now I'm
just asking the CNN to figure out what
are the visual features that are the
poor areas have and this is like a read
this is a really hard cast to do because
there's just not a lot of data so we're
trying to do this at the municipality
level in Mexico and there's 2,500
municipalities so this is this is this
is very hard and so a lot of people
would say this is impossible so we're
going to do transfer learning against
this so what we're gonna do is we're
going to take like an off the show
CNN model which truthfully I don't even
understand this like I understand the
end point we're all this is pre-trained
using imagenet so it's been seen like
millions of images it's learned like all
the intermediate like weights effect
effectively or excuse me
jared those are coefficients right yeah
yes okay so we're gonna learn all these
intermediate weights and at the end
we're just gonna replace whereas this
whole network is trying to produce to
figure out what like if it was a car or
maybe a cat or a dog or hot dog we're
gonna replace that last layer and just
say try to predict poverty like if you
learned all these intermediate things
that are useful for figuring out a hot
dog or not and now you're gonna figure
out if it's a poor neighborhood in
Mexico or a rich neighborhood in Mexico
and so this part was not done and this
was done in in Python and Theano and got
some details on on Mexico so we're using
two poverty levels kind of severe and
moderate poverty and then you know we do
some nice withholding of temperature
municipalities and but we're training
this off of 900 municipalities these are
the only municipalities that are
surveyed by Mexico it's supposed to be
representative but that's a separate
story and so we trained on 800 of these
and then we're going to see how performs
in the test sample so let's look how it
performs okay so it's not not a perfect
fit so we get our squares between 0.4
and 0.5 but still this is better like
imagine in a country where you have no
data whatsoever so this is and so see if
there's something else we can do so we
also can do land classification so we
could look at the we could ask asset to
train a classifier and say okay what
type of area is this is this a road is
this a building and I think this is
super cool because we trained this
against the planet satellites so this is
daily revisit rate meaning that this is
every road in Mexico and if you wanted
to you want to throw this algorithm
against new plant images you calculate
the changes in roads for Mexico and you
can do this anywhere in the world so I
just think this is like like
likes loads better than trying to do
surveys and then if we include this land
clapper classification or model and
improves it a little bit and we get
these predicted problems poverty for
urban areas in Mexico okay so what's the
lessons we can take away like I think I
think a lesson here is that like using
off-the-shelf data like if you were just
sitting in your art console trying to
trying to estimate something there's
this concept in economics like the
efficient market hypothesis so like if a
dataset is out there is it probably
somebody who was minded to write their
dissertation or to do some analysis so I
I think like if you are in a field where
prediction you're trying to predict
something in the real world and you're
using the same data that everyone else
has like you're probably not gonna do
better than them or better and the way
you would really get an edge is by just
generating some data that somebody else
doesn't have so you probably don't have
to go to the lengths that I'm going to
but like just try to get some new data
and in many cases generating new data or
getting some new data is going to be
better than using a better algorithm
okay so the second project I'm going to
talk about is really really recent stuff
the motivation here is we have a lot of
information on where violence is
occurring in the world but that
information is biased it's outdated and
it's imprecise
so it's a lot of the information on
violence it's recorded either by hand so
that there's some eyewitness who says
like there was a violent event here in
Syria in this location or it's actually
recorded from YouTube videos because
every like every Syrian army like has
like a YouTube video where they post and
say we bombed this building and so we
actually don't know the full extent of
damage or violence because maybe there
could be delay where when the videos
were posted or maybe there is some bias
and just what was reported if somebody
was there and if you think about this
you know like the point of bombs is that
they're supposed to have to do some type
of damage that should be visible some
space
this is an area in Homs Syria and you
can see that there are some there's some
detectable damage from these bombs and
so we can utilize some some of the same
computer vision technologies and we're
gonna so we can utilize that same
technology in order to tell whether an
area is a destroyed building or not and
this is the dream is that you're running
this in real time so this is running on
daily updated satellite images and like
we're like far away from that but we're
like inching towards towards that goal
so we located 380 training sites in
Syria with visual identified building
damage and we eventually want to
increase this to a thousand but right
now this just shows three and eighty
locations and then we do this process of
data augmentation which is like cropping
and stretching and skewing the the
images that increases this to five
thousand so we have about five thousand
images to Train off of and we're gonna
train two classifiers one for this
planet like fastly updated imagery and
the other one for the Google Maps API
okay the labeling process is pretty
straightforward we just pull up some
some image in Google Maps we're taking
1250 by 1250 images and then the label
we just try to figure out what do we
think is a is a destroyed area and so
anything that's destroyed area gets a 1
and everything else gets a zero and the
we're gonna ask the CNN to try to figure
out some type of mapping between those
two some visual mapping the architecture
is gonna be we're kind of starting from
a place we're using like a building
architecture like this is this has been
used attacking buildings so it's you
know it's it's kind of that's fancy
sandwich of things that are happening in
the CNN and if you do computer vision we
like there's there's 7 cnn's there's
that are they're stacked against each
other and then we take output for the
first the second and the seventh and use
that and create a stack feature map to
do pixel wise so the end result is we
get a pixel that says weather's the
destroyed building or not we do some
like advanced stuff because that wasn't
working out too well so I talk to my
like people who really do
computer vision because I'm an economist
believe it or not and like they say no
you want to use this you net
architecture so we kind of like make it
a little more fancy
all right training notes all this is
done in Theano it's run off Microsoft is
your server where where's mark
Heisman who's saying mark you were
saying like you're right
like like Microsoft Azure platform is
really fantastic
yeah it's really fantastic it's super
expensive though
so like so I'm burning through money
like I'm spending like a thousand
dollars a month so if you have credits
you can give me because aw AWS is they
offered me $30,000 and like I really
don't I really don't want to take my
research we'll talk okay can we talk
online no but he's absolutely I'm giving
a hard time but he's absolutely right
it's a great platform you can you can
load up a virtual server and we have 2k
80 GPUs and it takes about four days to
run but we're able to estimate the model
in that time and so all this is we're
all working off of a twenty thousand
dollar research grant from Lakeisha and
it's kind of you know we started this
like six months ago so and we can see
the preliminary learning anything that's
read as a building anything that's
that's not or is it anything that's read
a destroyed building and we see like
it's kind of learning that things
towards the top right are destroyed
buildings kind of starts out thinking
everything's destroyed building then it
stops and then the final after eight
hundred passes of the data we get
something that sort of closely
approximates the input and you could say
like every data scientist here is saying
that's super easy because that's an
in-sample so we can look at some of the
out-of-sample results and they look
pretty damn good so they're not perfect
we're still you know we're working
through the training data and the more
training day we throw into it the better
but they look pretty damn good if you
care about confusion matrices you can
roughly we're getting about 90% accuracy
at the pixel level so
next steps we really want to use this to
predict refugee flows this is where
we're actually economists is we're gonna
look at this from like a micro economic
standpoint people are making decisions
about where to go on the basis of is
there you know is there safety in this
certain areas and so we're having micro
economic models that are going to
predict where somebody travels to we
want to also analyze reporting biases
for different type of conflict and yeah
so what's the lesson here
so this is actually backwards you know
the data we're building our models and
like a lot of our statistics isn't based
around static data data comes in you get
like you get a CD you get some thumb
drive it comes in and we're building our
data off of that we're building our
models off that data and this our whole
project was on the idea of that like
data is going to be coming in real time
and we want to build our models that are
gonna incorporate that and so so maybe
maybe the goal here isn't necessarily to
build the best model to build something
that is useful for people on the ground
for humanitarian workers and so this is
I got this completely wrong because it's
a really dynamic model is gonna be
better than static model so static model
is going to break if it sees stuff in in
real time and it's not it's not able to
adjust so completely opposite lesson
here but okay all right so that's
everything I want to present so any
comments or suggestions are appreciated
if you want to give me money research
money that's great
or if you want to talk to me about group
lasso because I've got a project where
I'm where I'm doing some group lasso
stuff okay all right thanks so much
[Applause]
you